these are my best ever vegan chocolate
chip cookies so I really wanted to
create a vegan version of chocolate chip
cookies because there's such a classic
dessert so to replace an egg in a cookie
all I needed to use in the cookies was
almond milk but if you need something
that's gonna like find your dessert a
little bit more you can use a flax egg
you can use apple sauce you can use
banana there are so many options and so
many substitutes for eggs and vegan
recipes so it's super super easy so you
absolutely do not need animal products
to make a delicious vegan dessert all
you really need is flour some kind of
fat like oil and sugar and it's gonna
taste amazing people really think you
need eggs and you need butter but like
you really don't so when I made this
cookie I really wanted to stand up to
any non vegan chocolate chip cookie and
I really think I accomplished that I
gave it to my coworkers didn't tell them
it was vegan I just said hey I made some
cookies you guys want some and they were
like these are amazing and then when I
told them they were vegan they were like
how is that possible
so after you pull these cookies out of
the oven and you let them cool they're
going to be perfectly crisp on the
outside and chewy on the inside and in
my opinion that's exactly the texture
you want for a cookie I think I ate
about a thousand of these when I I think
I gained like 5 pounds when I was
shooting this video because I kept
trying to get that perfect pull apart
break of the cookie and I think it took
me I'm not exaggerating I think I had to
go through like 60 cookies to get it I
was just making more making more eating
more and when you like pull it apart and
you have it in your hand you just and
it's something that's that delicious you
put it in your mouth and you're like oh
my god I'm eating like thousands of
calories of cookies right now but I
cannot stop because it's taste like
magic
I have had people that I don't even know
tell me that they've made these cookies
and it honestly it makes me feel really
good this is one of those recipes that
I'm really proud of it's like a go-to
recipe for me and I make them at least
like I make them every Christmas and
it's just like become a staple now for
me so give them a try and you won't be
sorry you think a lot of people
associate vegan food with being healthy
and that's just not the case like sugar
is vegan or different kinds of
sweeteners are vegan and oil is vegan
and flour is vegan and if you have those
things you can make anything taste
delicious the bottom line is these
cookies are better for the animals
they're better for the environment and
they taste incredible so why not give
them a try
[Music]
you
[Music]